utilicen números simplificados cuando
hablamos la primera vez acerca de cómo
el gobierno chino puede intervenir en el
mercado de monedas para mantener su
moneda devaluada y lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es ver algunos de los
números reales esto viene de la oficina
de análisis económicos de los estados
unidos y esta es la dirección url de
donde tome esta información y esto de
que es el balance de pagos de eeuu con
relación a china esta parte de aquí es
la cuenta actual que nos indica las
exportaciones con respecto a las
importaciones y aquí está la cuenta
capital o la cuenta financiera
dependiendo de como la tomen en cuenta y
ese es el flujo financiero de entrada o
el flujo financiero de salida de la
propiedad de bienes estos son productos
y estos son bienes como dinero seguros y
cosas por el estilo y si vemos en el
2006 se exportaron algunas cosas hacia
china 72 mil 105 millones de dólares en
2006 así que estos 72 mil 105 son 72 mil
105 millones de dólares en 2007 85 mil
millones
mil 895 mil millones y en 2009 94 mil
millones más o menos bajó un poquito
pero se queda alrededor de los 95 mil
millones pero los eeuu importaron
muchísimo más en el 2007 se importaron
330 mil 821 millones de dólares 378 mil
millones aproximadamente en el 2007 casi
400 mil millones en 2008 así que por
ejemplo en el 2008 tenemos un déficit de
aproximadamente 300 mil millones de
dólares en el intercambio con china y en
el 2009 bajó un poquito este déficit
quedó en 260 mil millones y eso es
porque se importó eeuu importó un
poquito menos de bienes o de productos y
esto probablemente se debió a la
recesión en eeuu y esto se reflejó en el
consumo en general no sólo en los
productos que se compran de china por lo
que se compran menos bienes y servicios
debido a esta recesión y ahora veremos
la diferencia en la cuenta de finanzas y
así
punto esto nos narra la historia aunque
no nos narra toda la historia sobre los
dueños chinos que no sólo son del
gobierno chino sino de todos los chinos
que son dueños de bienes y todos ellos
están aumentando su compra de bienes de
eeuu estos bienes pueden ser bonos del
tesoro o letras del tesoro podrían ser
acciones de eeuu
o incluso propiedades en eeuu aquí
pueden ver que los estadounidenses están
comprando esta cantidad de bienes en
china cinco mil 531 millones de dólares
en 2006 2000 millones en el 2007
12000 millones en el 2008 y casi 19 mil
millones en el 2009 y esto está limitado
por reglas impuestas por el gobierno
chino pero pueden ver aquí que los
chinos están comprando muchísimos más
bienes en eeuu de lo que los
estadounidenses compran bienes en china
y esto es parte de toda esta realidad en
la que los chinos en particular el
gobierno central chino compran bienes de
estados unidos usando dólares que fueron
cambiados por yuanes y mantener al dólar
fuerte y mantener a su moneda devaluada
lo cual tiene mucho que ver para tener
este desequilibrio en las monedas los
dejo con algo para reflexionar
estos números de aquí tienen mucho que
ver con el desbalance en el déficit del
mercado sobre todo en el 2008 los chinos
compraron muchísimos bienes de lo que
había en el mercado pero en el 2009
vemos que no compraron lo suficiente
como para compensar el déficit en el
mercado solo compraron 143 mil millones
y viendo los números
de manera neta habrán comprado unos
120.000 millones de dólares pero esto no
compensa los 260 mil millones que vemos
acá y como es que a pesar de esto aún
mantienen fija su moneda y la respuesta
que veremos más adelante con más detalle
es que ellos no tienen que comprar
necesariamente bienes de eeuu
directamente pueden comprar bienes o
dinero de otros países lo cual pondrá
más presión en dicha moneda vamos a
escribirlo por acá
china puede ir y comprar moneda de eeuu
o puede hacer esto en otro país comprar
su moneda de este país
y ellos comenzarán a sentir la presión
su moneda se incrementará en valor y eso
va a dañar su mercado y este país a su
vez podría comprar bienes a eeuu para
mantener su moneda devaluada lo cual no
se mostraría en esta información de las
tablas veremos esto en más detalle en el
siguiente vídeo salman khan de khan
academy para cnc